madame plante merci d'être là bonsoir
bonsoir On aime les arbres moi je suis
un amoureux des arbres mais on
s'aperçoit chaque fois qu'un peu de
verglas il y en a eu quand même beaucoup
mais pas de temps comparé à la dernière
fois qu'on a des arbres vieux beaucoup
d'arbres vieux dans lesquelles Rosemont
Notre-Dame de Grâce au des neiges enfin
les quartiers qui ont été les plus
touchés
est-ce qu'on les entretient assez est-ce
qu'en amont on peut pas faire un blitz
pour qu'à chaque fois ça soit pas la
catastrophe comme ça mais des équipes
des mondes on a beaucoup à la Ville de
Montréal vous travaillez également avec
les équipes dans ce Cassie
d'Hydro-Québec à cause de du verglas
mais même en amont on travaille avec les
autres corps de travail pour s'assurer
que les armes sont bien entretenues dans
le ce qui s'est passé avec le verglas
qui est tombé c'est 360 arbres des bons
arbres qui sont tombés enfin je vais
quand même pas des branches est une
chose à peu près 1500 branches et mais
en termes
1500 branches
sinon 360 arbres qui ont été qui sont
tombés
c'est pas juste une question d'entretien
c'est que ça a été c'était lourd mais
nécessairement nous le travail qu'on
fait avec l'école bleue avec nos équipes
à la Ville de Montréal par
arrondissement c'est de nettoyer au fur
et à mesure parce que vous l'avez dit
c'est une richesse on a la chance à
Montréal d'avoir une ville très verte
quand on la compare à plein d'autres
villes c'est une richesse chaque fois en
prendre soin mais il y a pas une
inquiétude sur le type d'arbre je vais
pas faire une chronique avec vous là
mais sur le type d'arbre qu'on a planté
en 1930 1940 par exemple des grands
érables qui deviennent très grands qui
et qui sont fragiles qui sont plus
fragiles puis même on peut parler de
l'agrine du frein à un moment donné on a
plantait beaucoup et vous rappeler de la
petite bibite que manger les arbres
alors le fallu en couper plein alors
nécessairement on doit diversifier puis
il y a toute une recherche une analyse
au fur et à mesure comment est-ce qu'on
on rend notre forêt plus mixte c'est
plus résiliente aussi parce que des
citoyens m'ont écrit depuis ce matin en
disant on a appelé la ville disant qu'il
y avait où Hydro-Québec la ville où il
est où là disant qu'il y avait une sur
un fil ils viennent pas c'est long ça
les citoyens ont l'impression qu'on a
qu'on ne prend pas la mesure du problème
de la végétation quand arrive du verglas
il va en avoir de plus en plus on le
prend au sérieux honnêtement là encore
une fois si on regarde dans les
arrondissements les équipes sont
déployées puis tout au long de l'année
par rapport à
ces produits nécessairement c'est vrai
que ça amène une réflexion puis je vous
aviez l'adduction aussi avec Monsieur
fait ce qui est bien avant à savoir
comment est-ce qu'on rend notre
territoire plus résilient face aux
intempéries qui vont augmenter puis même
être plus fort avec les changements
climatiques là c'est du verglas on peut
parler des inondations on peut parler
des vagues de chaleur autant d'éléments
auxquels les villes on doit faire face
et c'est pas pour rien non plus qu'on
mange justement à nos collègues des
autres paliers comment est-ce qu'on aide
les villes à adapter leur territoire là
cette fois-ci on était chanceux nos
installations stratégiques n'ont pas été
touchées
usine d'eau au niveau des des parcs où
est-ce que les pilons hydroélectriques
rien a été touché mais ça aurait pu et
nécessairement il faut pouvoir mieux
adapter est-ce que c'est enfouir des
fils est-ce que c'est de faire plus de
parcs verts qui servent d'éponge il y a
beaucoup de solutions en fuir des fils
vous j'imagine que vous quelqu'un
monsieur Lego dit c'est 100 milliards
vous plaît des pas pour qu'on dépense
familiale là mais vous dites on pourrait
peut-être faire un bout de chemin là oui
oui absolument parce qu'on en est déjà
fait un bout de chemin on parle il y a
10 à 15 % des filles qui sont enfouis
dans le centre-ville c'est le cas on le
voit et d'ailleurs c'est vrai que moins
d'armes dans le centre-ville mais parce
que les filles sont enfouis ça leur fait
en sorte qu'on a pas vraiment de dommage
au centre-ville est-ce que tout le
territoire doit être enfoui si on parle
des coûts c'est à se poser faut se poser
la question moi je plaide pour rendre le
territoire les villes les municipalités
plus résiliantes de plein de façons au
niveau du hydroélectrique mais les
autres manières aussi il faut absolument
que nos territoires le plus absorber le
choc des des changements climatiques
qu'on soit préparé à affronter ces chocs
là qui vont arriver successivement ok
mais dernière question sur la végétation
bien ce que vous allez pas demander
qu'on fasse un autre tour de roue en
disant peut-être qu'on doit en faire
plus sur les branches sur la prévention
et au Québec avait pris du retard
beaucoup pour ça eux sont responsables
sur certaines territoires est-ce que la
ville devrait pas en faire plus je pense
qu'on peut toujours en faire plus la
réponse est non réaliste
après ça c'est définitivement en plus
comme notre administration qui rajoute
des armes des arbres et des armes et on
achète de plus en plus de terrain vert
donc nécessairement il faut que les
équipes suivent pour pouvoir comment
dire faire face de façon positive à
l'augmentation de la canopée à Montréal
ce qui est une très bonne nouvelle mais
les arbres que vous plantez aujourd'hui
sont venus adaptés sont mieux adaptés on
sait quoi planter de quoi ne plus
planter on en met plus d'érable
d'argenté qui sont aussi beaux mais qui
tombe au moindre verglass
les parcs vous fermez les grands parcs
en fin de semaine c'est trop dangereux
d'aller en effet en effet donc c'est
c'est seulement les grands parcs parce
qu'effectivement il y a trop de de
dommages parlent du Parc du Mont Royal
le parc Frédéric bac et a donc les
stationnements ne seront pas accessibles
et je demande vraiment aux soins citoyen
d'être extrêmement prudent on pourra pas
fermer mais des clôtures tout au long
des parcs mais même les parcs locaux
c'est pas une bonne idée en ce moment on
veut pas que les gens se blessent même
chose pour des gens qui verrai peut-être
une grosse branche sur leur voiture ce
n'est pas une bonne idée de l'enlever
par vous-même on veut pas d'accident et
en fait je mensuel et montréalens si
vous avez vous voyez camion Diderot ou
de la ville qui veut se stationner si
jamais vous pouvez changer votre voiture
de place pour les laisser travailler
allez-y puis en plus vous aurez pas de
tickets parce que c'est ce qu'on veut on
veut vraiment faciliter la vie au col
bleu aux gens du drone ou reconnecter
les foyers plus rapidement possible
et la met dans une zone où il y a pas le
droit de stationner il se Frot pas à
chalet avec un petit peu sauf les bonnes
fontaines parce qu'évidemment c'est des
questions de sécurité j'aime mieux le
mentionner
qui avait bien sûr évidemment mais je le
mentionne mais sinon effectivement on va
être très très clément on veut faire
autre chose flexibilité aujourd'hui
demain pour sûr et si c'est nécessaire
on va leur dire dans une communication
officielle ok dernière chose avant de
vous laisser aller le les gens qui
veulent aller prendre des douches qui
veulent c'est juste là et que ça peut
durer trois jours encore une fois ils
vont où ils font quoi ils appel qui
alors il y a déjà 500 qui sont en
opération qui est un à Saint-Léonard un
dans Villerest Saint-Michel par
extension un dans Notre Dame de Grâce un
dans Côte des Neiges et un autre à
verdun-le ça a été particulièrement
touché allez sur le site de la ville sur
le site toutes les adresses sont là et
vraiment j'invite les gens à aller vers
ces ressources là dormir au chaud
prendre une bonne douche et surtout
éviter de prendre des appareils de
chauffage là à la mitaine ou elle est
comment dire qui sont pas adaptés de
rentrer à la maison pas de barbecue dans
maison non plus non non
on veut pas d'accident on veut que tout
le monde soit en sécurité et si jamais
puis on le souhaite pas mais que ça se
prolongeait on verra en ajustrophe et
bien sûr l'idée c'est vraiment de
s'adapter l'objectif des gros-québec
c'est de rétablir 80% du réseau d'ici
demain minuit donc nous on suit leur
objectif mais on voulait être en mode
prévention n'hésitez pas moi y aller
montréalaise à vous prévenir à profiter
si je peux dire dans ce moment
extrêmement difficile mais il faut pas
faut pas mettre sa sécurité en jeu oui
tout à fait il y avait sur ma rue il y
avait un fil ce matin qui était là on
pouvait
toucher on aurait pu
très bien en effet merci Valérie plan
merci mes raisons Montréal à la
prochaine au revoir